cómo funciona este proceso que empieza
este miércoles en la corte idh y Por qué
es importante que el aborto se esté
debatiendo en ese tribunal
Qué tal Buenas tardes Gracias por el
espacio para nosotras es fundamental dar
a conocer todo lo que está significando
este momento histórico en la lucha por
la despenalización del aborto hace diez
años a Beatriz se le negó la posibilidad
de interrumpir un embarazo a pesar de su
condición de salud a pesar de lupus
eritematoso sistémico que ella tenía y
de la malformación incompatible con la
vida extrauterina del feto que estaba
pasado diez años y la Corte
Interamericana por primera vez conocerá
un caso específicamente de una mujer que
pidió un aborto y se le fue negado a
Beatriz cuando se le niega este servicio
la hacen pasar por una serie de hechos
de tortura fueron 81 días los que ella
tuvo que estar hospitalizada lejos de su
familia lejos de su comunidad además de
esto vivió amenazas de ser criminalizada
y se enfrentó al riesgo inminente de
perder su vida por este embarazo que no
era viable ahora la Corte Interamericana
tiene esta oportunidad histórica tiene
este momento que para nosotras como
feministas como defensora de Derechos
Humanos es clave porque puede generar
medidas de no repetición
la Corte Interamericana de Derechos
Humanos al condenar el estado
salvadoreño qué es lo que nosotras como
organizaciones representantes Esperamos
que suceda que se condene al Estado
salvadoreño por los tratos crueles
inhumanos y degradantes que vivió
Beatriz que genere medidas de no
repetición y que una de estas medidas
para que esta historia no se repita es
que cambien las disposiciones del Código
Penal es decir que se despenaliza el
aborto que las mujeres en El Salvador
podamos tener alternativas y podamos
realmente tener el derecho a decidir
esto Esperamos que también pueda generar
medidas de reparación integral para la
familia de Beatriz precisamente quería
preguntarle acerca de esas sanciones que
pudieran eventualmente salir de este
caso Cómo es Salvador tendría que verse
obligado a cumplir estos fallos por
parte de la corte ID las medidas de no
repetición de las cuales ustedes está
hablando
la Corte Interamericana de Derechos
Humanos es el máximo tribunal de las
Américas
cuando las ciudadanas cuando las
personas cuando las víctimas acuden al
sistema interamericano de Derechos
Humanos es porque se han agotado las
medidas se han agotado las posibilidades
para acceder a la justicia en el país
con Beatriz se agotaron diferentes
medidas Beatriz interpuso un Amparo ante
la sala de lo constitucional hizo una
serie de luchas para lograr que hicieran
este aborto y sin embargo no fue posible
y es por eso que el caso llega al
sistema interamericano al ser agotadas
todas las medidas que se podían hacer en
el país cuando el caso ingresa el
sistema interamericano de Derechos
Humanos en primera instancia lo conoce
la Comisión Interamericana de Derechos
Humanos Quién hace recomendaciones al
Estado salvadoreño
y a él las recomendaciones al no ser
acatadas al no ser retomadas pues la
misma comisión eleva el caso a la corte
que es el máximo tribunal y es la
instancia en donde hoy y mañana se está
conociendo el caso de Beatriz la
sentencia de la Corte Interamericana de
Derechos Humanos son de obligatorio
cumplimiento Ya lo hemos visto con otros
casos emblemáticos con otros casos muy
importantes en nuestro país como el caso
del mozote en donde una sentencia de la
corte incluso que miró reformas a nivel
de la amnistía